[Music]
patrick's with us in springfield
missouri hey patrick welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave
uh i am retired and i have 10 of my
retirement in gold and silver bullion
and coin
and my question is with the
disruptions in the economy due to
inflation the fed move the ukraine war
and possible
conflict with china in the future should
i
be invested in gold and silver
and if not is there an alternative
well i'm 61
and uh
i have a net worth of several hundred
million dollars
and i have zero invested in gold and
silver
it tells me a lot
uh and so you know it's consistent in
other words my advice is consistent with
what i do in the last 10 years uh gold
has averaged 3.6
while the stock market has averaged
almost 12.
and so i um
and and the problem is that gold and
silver are not necessarily
what people will run to
unless they're just afraid or greedy one
of the two
uh and in other words a failed economy
that would rely on gold and silver will
before it uh relies on that will turn
into a barter economy
so you know uh
the only way that i mean gold and silver
does not have intrinsic value it has
absolutely no value except what someone
else will pay you for it
uh gold our green president's faces
on paper don't have any value except
what someone else will trade you for it
and so that's how exchange or currency
works it's when we as a society or as a
group of people agree that something has
value we agree that little shiny clear
rocks have more value than the rocks in
our driveway and we call them diamonds
but it actually has no different they're
both a little rock
you know we just decided as a sir as a
society or a culture that there but
there's nothing that
automatically means that diamonds have
value
they don't
it's only because someone else wants
them that they have value and green
paper doesn't have value it's only it
doesn't it's only that someone else
wants it that makes it have value so all
of that to say anytime you're investing
in a commodity
because you're worried about world
affairs
or stupidity on a global scale or
whatever it is uh you're really not
accomplishing
what you hope to accomplish there
if you you know and so you you kind of
got to go extreme before these things
happen and if you believe that america
as we know it is getting ready to
implode which is not what you said
but for those of you out there that
believe that
then gold is really not where you put
your money you should put your money in
water bottle bottles of water bullets
blue jeans and gasoline practical things
because these utilitarian things are the
first things that happen in a completely
devastated
society you know you start fresh
and so and you know you could trade a
gallon of gas where there is no gas for
almost anything it becomes
like gold so what happens you end up
trying to trade your gold bar for a
gallon of gas it won't work nobody wants
it gold bart you just gotta carry your
stupid what are we gonna do with the
gold bar there was a youtube video of
this kid he tried to live on gold bars
for 24 hours as an experiment he
couldn't do it nobody nobody would take
it no one would take it and then he went
and rece he tried to resell it couldn't
get what he paid for it oh wow that was
a fun video fun experiment yeah but all
of that to say um
you know i
i'll throw in one other thing patrick
i'm being a little bit facetious but i'm
really not you probably need to turn off
the news
i think you've been spending too much
time watching the news
because everything you just outlined for
me is a talking point on a 24-hour news
cycle
and it's affecting your
brain more than it's affecting reality
um
i mean
reality is gas has gone up
and that's really biden's fault
reality is because he's you know went
all green and shut off the faucet
anytime you create a shortage on
something you create a price increase so
if you want to be if you want to blame
somebody for five or six dollar gas you
can look at your president he did that
if you want to blame someone for an
increase in
car prices
he did not do that
it's not his fault he had nothing to do
with it if you want to other parts of
inflation you want to say you won't
blame someone for house prices going up
it's not joe biden's fault he didn't do
it
can't blame him for that
uh because he there's no policy enacted
by the white house or at his behest
through congress that caused
those things those things are the result
of the a pandemic
that created a shortage that drove
prices up and so we have steel
prices are way up i'm building a
building up here commercial building
we're putting steel in it prices are
through the roof
we have a you know we have a shortage of
anything yeah yep
but a shortage of anything drives the
prices up
an oversupply of anything drives the
price down
it's seventh grade economics class it's
called a supply demand curve and that is
not joe biden's fault
and so when the news is on and they're
going well the biden administration and
the the average consumer polls are
saying that everyone's mad at the
president about inflation well they're
just uninformed you shouldn't be mad at
the president about inflation you'd be
mad at the pandemic
but there's no greedy you know boogeyman
out there trying to create inflation
it's going to smooth out over time the
only element of inflation that is his
fault and i'm 100 sure of this is is the
energy issue
and he shut off all domestic production
and so created
a dead gum shortage of oil and therefore
of gas and now you're having to pay
through the nose to get oil and gas and
we were buying 50 000 freaking barrels
from russia and guess what that's kind
of hard to do right now
so um
again
uh all in the name of being green
and so george could plug his car in
that's right thank you dave yeah we want
george to be able to plug his car in
it's important
that your toy car can be plugged in
their shots have been fired guys just so
you all know well listen dave aside from
that here's what's interesting you can
build incredible wealth and never turn
on the news
isn't that wild yeah higher probability
of it i i think we should do a study on
that
statistically you will become a
millionaire faster if you never turn on
the news well i do know this i do know
that um my stress level goes down yes my
tendency to rage at something that has
nothing to do with anything goes down
well they're getting better at writing
these headlines makes you click it makes
you angry
that's how this works yeah and it's all
of us are that way so just jumping in on
there on you patrick but um you know i
my money is in good growth stock mutual
funds and in real estate that i pay cash
for
that's all i own
i don't know anything else so sell sell
all that off and put in mutual funds
you'll be better off in the long run man
i'm unusually heavy
in real estate but it's because i'm a
real estate guy i got my real estate
license in 1978 i've been doing real
estate a long time i'm really
comfortable with dirt really comfortable
bricks and mortar really comfortable
being a landlord
doesn't bother me a bit other people
shouldn't do that because you're not
comfortable with it but
you know real estate
i'm there mutual funds i'm there